in this video you're going to learn how
to do two column proofs involving
proving triangles congruent and we're
going to go through five different
proofs together we're going to do one of
each of the different types side side
side side angle side angle side angle
angle angle side and hypotenuse leg and
if you've been having trouble
understanding this concept I'm going to
show you some tips and techniques as we
go through to make this a little bit
easier so let's dive into the first
example we're given that AB is parallel
to CD Now whenever you think of the
Givens think of them as clues or hints
and take the moment to just write this
on the diagram so that you don't have to
remember it you can kind of visualize it
or see it and that's what I'm doing with
these arrows I'm showing those are
parallel and ab is congruent to CD so
I'm just going to put the corresponding
little Dash there to show that they're
the same length we want to prove that
the triangles are congruent but again
think of the Givens as clues or hints
like why are they telling us that these
lines are parallel well you remember
probably from a earlier chapter parallel
lines okay I like to extend them a
little bit when they're parallel like
this cut by a
transversal what do we end up having
well we end up having angles that are
congruent and in this particular problem
you can see that this angle and this
angle are congruent by alternate
interior angles right so they're in
between the two parallel lines one's on
the right one's on the left side of the
transversal and they're going to be
congruent to each other when you figure
something out you're going to want to
put that as a step in your proof but
normally what we do is we start with
writing the Givens as our first step you
don't have to sometimes people will
scatter them a little bit through the
proof as they go but most students what
they'll do is they'll just list these
Givens right here in the first step so
I'm going to say AB is parallel to
CD okay and
also um we'll say AB is congruent to CD
and we're just going to say that that's
given but for step number two we figured
out that these angles were congruent by
alternate interior angles I'll just
abbreviate AIA for alternate interior
angles and notice that there's more than
one angle at this vertex so I'm going to
say angle
DCA is congruent to
angle B
A okay now let's look at what we have
here we've got this side and this side
are congruent these angles are congruent
and then notice that these two triangles
they share this side in between them AC
so AC is going to be congruent to AC by
the reflexive property remember it's
just like looking in a mirror your
reflection in the mirror like you're the
same height in the mirror as you are in
real in real life so we call that the
reflexive property I'll just sit right
reflexive I'm just going to abbreviate
now do we have enough information to
prove these two triangles congruent now
remember triangles are actually consist
of six pieces of information you have
three sides and three angles
but by showing these specific components
are congruent that's enough to show that
the whole triangle is congruent and we
only really need three pieces and in
this case you can see the angle is in
between the two sides that's called the
included angle and that would be the
side angle side so this is proving the
triangle is congruent by side angle side
and remember whatever you're trying to
prove that's going to be the last step
in your proof here so this is going to
be step number four here triangle
ABC is congruent to Triangle
CDA now another important thing when
you're looking at these triangle
congruence statement it tells you how
things should match up like a right
should match up side CD see first and
second first and second or BC should
match up with da or AC should match up
with CA
Etc let's take a look at another example
okay for example number two try this one
if you feel like you're getting the hang
of this we're given that and I'm just
abbreviating and G forgiven D is the
midpoint of AC now why is that a clue or
a hint well midpoint means it's in the
middle right so that means that this
length should be the same length as that
length so let's put that as a step in
our proof now I'm going to jump down to
step number two step number one we
already mentioned that that's going to
be our given right so we can just draw a
little arrow here for the given but step
number two we can see that a d is
congruent to CD a d is congruent to C CD
and that's the
definition I'm just going to abbreviate
of midpoint abbreviating okay now notice
when I figure something out I like to
mark it on the diagram again so I don't
have to remember all that information
they also tell us that ba is congruent
to BC So ba is congruent to this length
BC again marking it on the diagram so I
don't have to remember it that's in our
given now anything else that's congruent
between the two triangles any sides or
any angles there's a couple different
ways to do this problem I mean one way
to do it would be to say that oh I can
see that this is an isoceles triangle
and the base angles are congruent that's
one option but here I think I'm just
going to take the easy rote here by
noticing that this side is shared
between these two triangles it's kind of
like if you go back to back with a
friend say oh we're the same height
because you're back to back see how the
triangles are are right next to each
other so we know that
ad is congruent to
itself a d and you'll notice that this
comes up a lot in proofs the reflexive
property anything is going to be
congruent to itself now do we have
enough information to show these
triangles are congruent yes we've got
three sides are congruent to three sides
that's our side side side and so that's
going to be our last step number four
remember whatever you're trying to prove
goes in the last step and the reason is
SSS or side side side let's take a look
at another example okay see if you can
do number three now we've got uh our
given that angle a is congruent to angle
e so let's mark that on the diagram
these angles are the same and we've got
segment AE
bcts uh segment BD now what does that
mean that AE is bisecting segment BD
well we know I means two SE means to
like intersect or cut so which segment
is cutting which segment well AE is the
segment that's cutting BD in half so
that tells us that BC is congruent to CD
let's put that as a step in our proof so
when you figure something out again the
clues are uh in the Givens there and we
can sometimes it's just a gimme like
they just kind of gave us this
information which I marked so that's
going to go in Step number one all of
our Givens but for step number two we
figured out that BC is congruent to DC
and that's by the
definition of
segment bis sector okay I'm just
abbreviating so a lot of times you'll
notice that the reasons they're going to
be theorems but they're also going to be
definitions and it's just definition of
segment bis sector the last one we had a
definition of midpoint definition of
supplementary angles a lot of times
you'll see that it's just the
definition now is there anything else
that's congruent between these two
triangles any sides or any
angles well notice that whenever you see
like an X like this where two lines
intersect the angles that are across
from each other those are going to be
congruent those are called vertical
angles so what we're going to do here
for step number three is we're going to
say angle
ACB is congruent
to
angle uh let's see what is this
ecd and that's by the vertical angle
congruence theorem I'm just going to
abbreviate VA vertical angles sometimes
students will say oh uh angle C is equal
to angle C but notice when there's more
than one angle at a given vertex at a
given point to be clear you want to use
three points make sure that middle
letter is the hinge or the vertex of the
angle now do we have enough information
to prove that these two triangles are
congruent using one of these over here
on the right well it looks like we've
got angle angle side angle angle side
it's like if I was to take this triangle
and rotate it those components would
match up with one another and that's
enough to prove that the entire uh
triangles congr to the entire triangle
now when you do these uh okay you want
go around the triangle you want to go
like in order like angle the next angle
you come to the next side you come to
you don't want to do like some random
like angle you know what I mean you go
around in order clockwise or
counterclockwise okay um you don't want
to skip around okay so now we said that
the triangles are congruent that's going
to be our last step in our proof what
we're trying to prove and we said that
was by angle angle side and you got it
let's take a look at another example see
if you can do example number four we've
got BD is perpendicular to AC and BD
bcts angle ABC so why are those clues or
hints that's what we want to figure out
remember our first step we always want
to list our our Givens okay that's
usually uh common practice amongst a lot
of students just to kind of get that out
of the way sometimes it is helpful to do
them one at a time like if you're
addressing this given you might want to
put that first and then what you kind of
derive from that and then take the next
given what you derive from that but for
this one we're just going to put the
Givens in our first step uh for number
two now why do they tell us BD is
perpendicular to AC well we know when
it's perpendicular it's going to form a
right angle right and so let's go ahead
and write that down so we're going to
say uh angle a
DB is a right angle I'm going to
abbreviate and angle C
DB is a right angle and the reason for
that again another definition it's it's
the definition of perpendicular I'm just
abbreviating now we can take this one
step further and we can say now that
angle a DB is congruent to angle C DB
and that's by the right angle
congruence theorem meaning that all
right angles are congruent to all of the
right angles they call that the right
angle congruence theorem now taking this
other given that BD segment BD bcts
angle ABC what does that mean well we
talked about how by means two SEC means
cut but it's cutting an angle now in
half this top angle ABC so if it bcts it
that tells us that these two guys are
going to be congruent to one another and
we want to list that as a step in our
proof whatever we figure out so angle a
b d is congruent to angle c b d and the
reason
is definition of angle I'm just
abbreviating bis sector okay now is
there anything else that's congruent
between these two triangles well again
you can see that BD is shared between
these two triangles so by the reflexive
property we know that BD segment BD is
congruent to segment BD and that is
reflexive just like looking at a mirror
you're the same height in real life as
you are in the mirror now do we have
enough to prove that the two triangles
are congruent that's our goal that's
what we're trying to prove well we can
see we have angle side angle the side
this is called the included side it's in
between these two angles that's this guy
right here angle side angle so let's go
ahead and make that what we're trying to
prove the last step in our proof right
here and the reason we abbreviate ASA
angle side angle let's take a look at
one last example okay so for this last
example try it if you want to uh get
some practice but we're given this angle
ABC ab C is a right angle so let's mark
that and we're told that angle DBC is a
right angle so oh I meant for this to be
DCB my mistake DCB is a right angle
that's this guy right here okay so we'll
mark that we also know that AC is
congruent to BD so let's see AC is
congruent to BD now what's interesting
about this problem we want to prove
these two triangles are congruent
triangle ABC and triangle DCB that's
this big triangle here and this big
triangle here they're overlapping and so
what I oftentimes recommend to students
when they're overlapping is to pull them
apart and draw them separately and
that's what I did down here it's a
little bit easier to analyze when
they're like that and we can Mark these
as well so this is a right angle and
this is a right angle that was given and
they also told us that AC was congruent
to BD okay so that's interesting now
let's go to our our proof we know we're
putting our given here in the first step
say given but step number two you see
how these angles are both right angles
so let's say that angle AB C is
congruent to angle DCB and the reason is
um right angle congruence theorem right
right angle congruence theorem all right
angles are congruent to all the right
angles we could also state in Step
number three that triangle ABC triangle
ABC is a right triangle in and triangle
uh
DCB is a right triangle and that's the
definition of a right triangle if it has
a right angle uh then that's a right
triangle right so now what we're going
to do is we're going to say that uh and
this is where students kind of Miss see
because the two triangles are
overlapping if I pull them apart see how
this is BC and BC they originally shared
that side so BC is going to be congruent
to itself s by the good old fashioned
reflexive property right we've seen that
a lot today in these proofs so BC is
congruent to BC reflexive sometimes
students miss this one because of it's
hard to kind of notice that it's not
like the two triangles are side by side
they're actually overlapping at that
that side
there and now do we have enough
information to prove that these two
triangles are congruent well we know
that they're right triangles we also
know that the hypotenuse is diagonally
across from that right angle and those
are congruent and we have one leg that's
congruent to one leg that's what we call
our hypotenuse leg theorem it looks at
first glance like there's only two
components H and L like hypotenuse and
leg but in order for it to have a
hypotenuse it also has to be a right
triangle or have that right angle so
there really is three components here uh
remember with these triangles you cannot
prove triangles congruent by angle angle
angle uh there's no angle side side or
side side angle these are
not ways to prove triangles congruent
just these five but in this last example
what we're trying to prove is going to
be our last step and we said that that
was because of the hypotenuse leg
theorem so great job if you're able to
follow all these uh triangle congruence
proofs if you want more practice I'll
try to put a playlist right there with
some more triangle congruence to column
proo like this so you can get some
additional practice I'll see you over in
those videos